say hello
[Music]
here
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
doing sick
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
last time we knocked
next time
[Music]
yes
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
get this
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm saying
[Music]
[Music]
just stop okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sleep
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
see them
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
you
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're the people last night
[Music]
you wouldn't even talk to me
i'm so crazy
[Music]
make it
[Music]
baby give it to me
[Music]
give it to me give it to me
[Music]
i don't like just dancing
baby
give it up
[Music]
just girlfriends
[Music]
give me is smoke
[Music]
give it to me
[Music]
give it to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sunrise
it's just the beginning
it doesn't change
[Music]
it's
[Music]
the same people you misuse on your way
[Music]
up
[Music]
when you're
[Music]
it's high time
[Music]
on the way down
[Music]
you but the
[Music]
you same around
[Music]
i myself
the same people you walk on on your way
up
[Music]
you can get it
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
what's going faster this is
mystery
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
sadness
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
next
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
we're just like
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
are you changing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yeah yep
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get the stuff together don't worry about
nothing else
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
stuck in your feet
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
give me
[Music]
um
you know i wouldn't have enough
[Music]
collard greens and black
[Music]
huh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
all right
in the right place
[Music]
so
see my life
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
me
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dancing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay thank you
[Music]
let's stop chasing
faster
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
my
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
everyday
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
videos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
times
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
get it
[Music]
do it right
[Music]
everybody over there
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
wait
wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come
[Music]
what's the matter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
surprised
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
smiling
in your eyes
[Music]
hey
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever it is
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't do it
you've got
[Music]
it's your thing you do what you want to
do
do what you want to do
just as bad as i do
[Music]
is do what you wanna do tonight
all right
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
how can you do
[Music]
[Music]
it's your favorite
[Music]
my place
[Music]
evening
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
everybody
and every time we went to
a certain room
[Music]
everybody's
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
you oh
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
around
[Music]
y'all
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
frank spencer general vice president of
the united brotherhood of carpenters
james callahan general president of the
international union of operating
engineers
and the next president of the united
states joe biden
good evening my name is frank spencer
and i'm the general vice president for
the united brotherhood
of carpenters and joiners of america
general president mccarran isn't able to
be here today
so it's my honor on behalf of our 550
000 men and women that we represent
to endorse joe biden for president
and kamala harris for vice president
you're welcome vice president
you know leaders stand up for what's
right
even when it's hard that's joe biden
leaders tell the truth even when it's
inconvenient
that's joe biden leaders understand
that the strength of our country is tied
to the strength of the middle class
that means strong unions protection for
workers
and a fair tax policy
joe biden knows that joe
stands with working americans and knows
the value
the union brings to our communities
joe stands with working carpenters and
because of that
we're proud to stand with joe biden the
next
president of the united states thank you
good evening my name is james callan
i'm the general president of the
operating engineers
400 members strong 400 000 members
strong
and it's our honor to have the next
president of the united states
tour our great local 66
training center that underscores
what we do in labor and if we didn't
have to it wasn't a far reach to explain
to someone like joe biden what working
americans do
i want to thank jim kuntz the president
and vice president
of local 66 my secretary treasurer brian
hickey who's flown in from chicago
to underscore and relay
to vice president biden that we at our
general executive board
wholly endorse him
and senator harris for the next ticket
of the president and vice president of
the united states
as joe said to us many times
he understands what a paycheck does
to working people not a dividend check
for people that are just waiting for a
dividend check
on their savings or their investment he
understands
that people live check to check and the
guidance that go with that
and the way that this administration
current administration
wants to tear that down
so we wholeheartedly endorse as the next
president
of the united states joe biden
thank you very much
better not touch it oh everybody
it's great to be here i just want
the record to show that
jim promised if i get elected
president united states i can go down to
houston facility and work and try to
drive in this machinery i get a shot at
i used to have a license to drive
tractor trailers but i tell you what i'm
looking to
get that sucker that big caterpillar
that's a good one
but i'm not sure i want to try that
crane man that looks awful that looks
awful tough
i know well i'll tell you what
it's great to be here you know there was
an old expression
when i was growing up in scranton you go
home with them that bring you to the
dance
and labor brought me to the dance a long
long time ago
they're the ones who are the operating
engineers and the carpenters
early on first time that i ran
people who laid the tracks in the
pipeline to operate
the cranes and shape the skyline and
build the foundations
of everything we rely on labor as i said
brought me to the dance not an
exaggeration
and the only reason i'm standing here
today as a candidate for president
if i hadn't been for the labor back in
1972 when i was a 29 year old kid
just after labor day i was losing the
election i think it was 54 to 19
going into the election and then labor
came on board
carpenters across the board just up and
down
operating engineers the steel workers
and we ended up winning by a
overwhelming margin of 3 200 votes
statewide when nixon won the state with
68
of the vote so i don't forget
and my dad used to have an expression
for real
he said the only way to deal with the
abuse of power joey is with power
and the only people can take on
the major corporate interests and the
oligarchs who are abusing power
the working men and women are organized
labor that's not
that's not an exaggeration the only ones
the only ones and that's why i've been
so supportive of labor
my whole career i've never forgotten
everything
that they've done for me you've done for
me but not just for me but for the
country
you are literally not figuratively the
backbone of america
the military is the spine of america
you're the backbone of america
an awful lot of you served in the
military as well
you're the ones who actually built this
country
not wall street bankers and ceos you
built the country
and you're going to build it you're
going to build it back better than it
was before
i want to thank uh jim i want to thank
president callahan
and his team as well as the folks in
local 66 for welcoming you here today
and giving us
an inside look at everything you're
doing to rebuild and energize
western pennsylvania i'm from eastern
pennsylvania i'm from up in lackawanna
county
in that valley and a lot a lot's gonna
happen here
i'm i am so confident i really am
that we're not only coming back we're
gonna come back big i mean
i mean hard-working folks i want to
thank vice president frank spencer and
the carpenters
for all they do as well i'm honored to
trust you please do me and i want to
thank you a lot for it
and if i have the honor of becoming
president i'll be fighting for you every
single day and i promise you
hear me now you will have a seat at the
table at the white house
no fundamental decision will be made
without you sitting
in literally not figuratively literally
that's a word you have my word on it
and folks you know i've i've been on a
train today
i've traveled this kind of like going
back home i
i traveled over 2 million 100 000 miles
over
40 years on amtrak going back and forth
every single solitary
night to see my kids a 250 mile round
trip
but we came today we ran around an
amtrak train to a whistle stop tour
we started off in cleveland across ohio
into western pennsylvania
and riding the rails uh reminds me of
when i would
train home from wilmington to washington
and back
every night and i used to go back when
you get through beyond the beltway going
into baltimore
you go through a number of middle class
neighborhoods
like houses like like i grew up in three
bedrooms putting little homes that kind
of thing
and i used to literally when we'd have
debates on the floor
of the senate and look out that window
and i sit there and i see the lights on
and the homes we're passing just like we
saw
coming from cleveland and the pittsburgh
and pittsburgh to here
and i wonder do they have the same kind
of conversations at that table
that my mom and dad had at our table
are they having the same kind of
conversation as the guys i grew up with
and women i grew up with dad
no honey we can't get four new tires in
the car we can't
we can't afford it we got to wait
another month literally
not figuratively literally or you know
i know i you know i i know we need a new
hot water heater
but we can't afford it we got to wait
it's going to take a little while longer
you have vast majority of the middle
class saying before we got into this
recession
that they got a bill for for an
unexpected bill for 400
in a month that they didn't expect that
you have to borrow the money
or put it off
they're neighbors i grew up in
you're the only ones that have saved
them from people from having to do that
if in fact you're able to have work you
know folks
i knew all those families inside and
those families
and on that route today i didn't know
their names
but i know was on their minds what their
concerns were
they're not looking for a handout all
they're looking for is a hand up
my dad used to say joe i don't expect
the government to solve my problems but
i sure didn't
expect to understand my problem
we're not understanding the problems of
the vast majority of americans today
all looking for is a fair shot and a
little bit of dignity
and a little bit of respect instead of
being looked down on
so that the parents could look their
kids in the eye and say honey
everything's gonna be okay my dad just
had that expression and jobs a lot
well after we left scranton and he had
to move to delaware and commute every
day for
over a year and then finally be able to
get us down every day
once a week come back every week
and finally we got to go to we got
apartment and climb on delaware a little
still town and has no more steel now
but uh and then we finally ever get it
home four years later
but you know it's um
it's what a lot of people are still
going through
there's a stark difference from what i
saw last night on the debate stage
an entitled self-serving president
who inherited everything in his life and
squandered it
president who calls his own supporters
according to
some staff members his own supporters
disgusting who thinks that folks who put
their lives on the line for our country
in the military are losers
and suckers it's despicable
i've dealt with guys like trump my whole
life
the guys might let you park the cars at
their country club pick up a few bucks
but even if you had the money wouldn't
let you join that country club
because you're religion or because of
your background
ties to stiff contractors building their
hotels and their golf
courses just to put a few more bucks in
their pocket it seemed to take some joy
in it
guys who think the rules don't apply to
them
guys that make tens of millions of
dollars and pay 750 dollars in federal
taxes
in a year
donald trump sees things from park
avenue
i seen from where i grew up in scranton
and clemont
my mom gene finnegan biden
had a backbone like a ramrod all five
foot one of her
but my mom used to have an expression i
really mean it
i used to be a stutterer and it's when
you're studying used to bullies
it's easy to make fun of somebody who to
talks like that
that's how i learned to fight the joke
used to be bride's like shoe leather
you can beat him but he's going to hurt
you
because you have to stand up to these
folks well
my mom would say joey look at me look at
me
remember nobody is better than you
nobody but everybody's your equal
and she meant it she meant it
as i said you know my dad's expression
when we moved to delaware so you talk
about how
a job is a lot more than a lot of
paycheck it's about your dignity it's
about respect
it's about your place in the community
those values shaped my whole life
if you look back on my career you notice
it shaped my whole career
my buildback better plan it shape my
views as president
what i'll do it's all about giving
communities like greensburg
and new alexandria and claymont and
scranton
and places in parts of cleveland i just
came out of
given women and men who work on
pipelines and construction
sites a fair shot we're gonna invest
two trillion dollars in infrastructure
including more than 50 billion in one
year
to get to repairing our schools our
highways our bridges revitalizing our
locks and our dams
making our inland waterways the finest
in the world that's what attracts
businesses
that's what brings employment they talk
about how much my plan cost
well guess what those investments can
take
millions of high-paying jobs building a
modern infrastructure and a durable
energy future
and i promise you this in my
administration
collective bargaining now hear me
collective bargaining will be sacred
it's a guarantee a guarantee
and union apprenticeships union
apprentice would be sacred
the last thing we need is corporate
america taking over apprenticeships
programs like they tried to do
we're going to stand up for prevailing
wage and benefit predictions of the
davis bacon act
i had i guarantee
[Applause]
you may recall the president who used to
like to surprise me at
state of the union address it says and
sheriff joe will take care of
the bill back and we can call bill back
better as a recovery act
800 billion not a single project was not
prevailing wage
it was a guarantee every single solitary
project we built
and so folks we're going to level the
playing field
for you and for your families we're
going to have
wages and benefits we're going to lower
health care costs
prescription drug prices we're going to
take on the opioid crisis for real
with effective treatment making four
years of
public college universities apprentice
programs tuition free
making less than 125 thousand dollars a
year
if they go to a state university they go
to a community college it's
automatic or if they're in the tennis
program
it's going to be free my wife has an
expression she's a community college
professor
any country that out educates us will
out-compete us
and the cost is staggering for people
having to carry the burden
and we're gonna do without asking anyone
who makes under four hundred thousand
dollars a year to pay
one more penny in taxes guarantee
my word on it because what we're gonna
do
we're gonna get rid of that
two trillion dollar tax cut that trump
passed
1.4 trillion are going to the top one
percent
significant portion that going to the
top one tenth of one percent
we're going to start rewarding work not
wealth
we're going to make sure corporations
begin to pay their fair you know
the fortune 500 companies 91 don't pay a
single penny in taxes and some of them
make multi-billion dollars
how about your taxes you pay no nothing
in taxes
we're not going to punish anybody
everyone's going to pay their fair share
look a lot of people around here
voted for donald trump last time i get
it i understand why i've been asked many
times in recent years
how do we get to a place where the
people who teach our kids take care of
our sick
build our bridges operate our cranes who
race into burning buildings and don't
ask who's in the other in there whether
you're black or white or
muslim or christian people who
who in fact grow our food
how do we get to place where they don't
think we don't see them
or hear them or respect them
well i see them i hear them
i respect them i know them they're
family
and it's going to change it's going to
change with me
look this is not a partisan moment this
is an american moment
and i mean that seriously think about it
we have a chance to put the anger and
division
has overtaken this country behind us
we can be what we are at our best
one people one america
we just need to remember who in god's
name we are
this is the united states of america
think about this never once in our
history
when we've set our mind to it have we
not been able to accomplish whatever we
set our mind to
when we've done it together there's not
a single thing we can't do
and with your help i'm going to get
elected
and with us working together i promise
you
i promise you there's going to be a
different america
we again reward work not just wealth
for people are treated with decency
i'll conclude by saying a president's
words matter
no matter how good or bad a president is
the words they utter matter they can
take us to war
they can bring peace it can make the
market rise or fall
you can change people's lives
this president has
breathe hate and division under the
rocks here
hate only hides it doesn't go away
and it matters what presidents say
you heard he said last night when it was
asked
by the moderator when you condemn white
supremacy
and he fuddled around didn't say
anything i said how about the proud boys
and he said well and contacted lexy said
just tell them to stand down and stand
by go online
a good problem is they got a new emblem
now literally
it says stand down and stand by
implying that if he loses the election
something may have to be done
i promise you that won't happen
the american people are going to speak
they're going to speak in large numbers
and nobody is going to get in the way
of our democratic process going forward
nobody
period this is the united states of
america
we're not something born dictatorship or
a third world country
this is the united states of america so
thank you all for your endorsement i
really mean it it means a lot to me
personally
it's on a personal level i appreciate it
so god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you so very much
[Applause]
[Music]
and try to find peace